maybe Trump did it you know maybe he
committed crimes maybe he's not being
indicted because he's running for
president maybe he actually did steal
classified documents which there's a lot
of evidence to support maybe he did
commit Rico in Georgia which there's
evidence to support maybe he did enter
into a criminal conspiracy to defraud
the United States which there's evidence
to support maybe he just did it like
there's so much evidence against Donald
Trump and then Trump just says no it's
political well the argument I mean the
RICO thing is so insane that the first
example he used is a great one says
maybe he did have the classified
documents okay first of all he was the
president of the United States he had
the authority to declassify at
will whatever he wanted to but second of
all the evidence that his prosecution
would be political rather than merely
criminal or legal is that Hillary
Clinton who had no authority to
declassify documents at will committed
the very same crime